I walk into the house and stick my hand
out to come the first time I think you
look at it over that we're all upstairs
and I just chatting when I suddenly
noticed there's no color move Charles
upstairs
so this disturbs me so I make my way to
go downstairs Finn I know what I'm going
to prove that myself
try to stop if we're going downstairs
don't know don't go down there I'm just
gonna fry my husband I go downstairs
it's a very happy - threesome going on
downstairs I'm gonna childhood in my
home I don't know change anyone it's not
like this is your moment
it's how exactly I'm joining the
conversation just oh my best friend and
I said coming I'd love to have a word
you know I got really uncomfortable for
the head - oh yes I said to me okay boys
you should come and I'll be out for a
minute and they shot upstairs like
chickens in their heads and I could feel
upstairs or how breaking with what she
going to do it's I said commitments to
accept mmm I was a terrified them and I
said come and I just like to enjoy new
it's actual experiment which is I don't
know what recovery life that's what I
know it's very much a management
and she said to the baby she said we've
got everything you'd ever want to Oh
tribute which anything you want I don't
even know what she said anyway so I said
I want one husband and she said brightly
she looked down the whole time I said to
feel I'm sorry I'm in the way I don't
see how to anyway I don't need to be
happy
[Music]
in the car labor Mahajan was over me
like a bad rash I cried like a Democrat
for it was anger it was seven years of
pent-up anger yeah
cry and deceit that night and you're
next when we work out when I thought
different shift to mentorship I'd done
something said what I felt still the old
Jemison universe running around but it
wasn't so death as it's been before and
I said to him but the we came through
they say I said Oh Diane Sawyer watch
there what I thought you coming up
there's no secret to me ask her I just
said I loved you with nothing morning